Please join me in welcoming,
uh,
to Google Seattle,
Mashallah.
Y'All Keana
[inaudible].
Marsha is a founding member of pussy riot and a political activist.
She is also an author,
poet,
musician,
mother of a young son and an actor having appeared as herself in an episode of
House of cards and on stage this week in Seattle in the bellows free theater's
production of burning doors,
which is a play based on her life.
And those have two other activists which runs through this Sunday at on the
boards and tickets remain available.
Uh,
I understand it's a great production.
her memoir of her time as a prisoner of conscience in Russia.
Riot days was published three days ago,
and as I told Matia am roughly halfway through reading it,
uh,
myself,
with her fellow,
a pussy riot member,
uh,
Nadia,
a Taconic over,
uh,
she founded Zona [inaudible],
an organization which defends prisoner's rights.
She's a recipient of the Lennonono grant for peace as well as the Hannah Aaron
to prize for political thought.
So,
uh,
I've mentioned the books will be for sale,
after,
uh,
after we're done.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and I think a bit about the format.
So let's get right into some questions.
Are you ready?
Thinks about me even though.
Okay.
Well,
uh,
if,
if any question is,
is,
uh,
out of bounds or uncomfortable for you,
that's perfectly all right.
But let's get,
let's get right to it.
Um,
I,
I want it to get to the events that are the focus of riot days.
Uh,
but before we do,
could you just tell us a bit about your life in Russia prior to the founding of
Pussy riot?
You know,
where were you born and raised?
Um,
what was your life like growing up?
maybe a bit about your education and how you formed your social and political
consciousness.
I was born in Moscow,
um,
in 1998,
which is a amazing time in Russia is troika time.
So it's kind of the end of a Soviet Union and,
uh,
rising up Russia.
Um,
so when my boss per time from years,
et Cetera,
but this last year of USSR.
Excellent.
Um,
my mother,
she's a program is mmm.
Like Prague dumbest.
And my father,
he's,
um,
Matthew mathematics professor.
Uh,
and uh,
well I was,
um,
I was growing up with my mother,
so I met my,
my father like when I was Jen ager.
And,
uh,
um,
there were no,
almost no talking politics in our family,
but some called why was a kind of a problematic child?
So I,
I changed the m five schools.
Um,
all of them I left by myself because I hated the system of education.
So coated education,
uh,
because it's totally Soviet Union system in which they want you to follow the
rules,
but not asking questions.
And I love questions.
So,
um,
that's how I think it's all started.
And,
um,
before pussy riot I was,
uh,
well it's,
it's a big,
big circle of,
uh,
of uh,
30 different people.
For example,
I started,
oh my,
let's say activism from a ecology when I knew that some government officials
close to former presidents,
so off and Medvedev wants to cut the forest.
I really love,
I start a campaign,
like a small campaign.
We were like five people meeting on the subway and collecting signatures.
But after one year that was more than 10,000 people around Russia and we won.
But in the end of the story,
I was quite,
well,
I understood that a,
it's a Tokyo rose situation when,
uh,
you need to do everyday activism for like making the results of one signature of
one fucking government official.
And,
um,
I started you to know to,
to how to say it.
Hm.
Do you about the different forms of protest.
And I started to read about political art.
I started to,
uh,
needs different people and that's how I think
we should I started.
So yeah.
So there was a significant transition in Russian society at the start of the new
millennium when uh,
between Boris Yeltsin and [inaudible] Yep.
I was president of,
of Russia.
And uh,
in,
in your book you write about this,
um,
you note that at the time Putin said we need stability.
Uh,
and then you go on to say,
uh,
you,
you go on to say stability was what he called himself.
Yeah.
Could you expand on that a bit?
What is this notion of stability,
um,
in your mind?
Well,
yes,
this is one of the,
of his favorite words,
the ability,
but it's not a,
it's a hippocratic shit.
It's not about stability.
It's about being a president until he will die and stealing money from Russian
people and spending them in their circles.
So it's not about to be lit.
You,
um,
actually,
uh,
we went to the Christ Cathedral of Christ the savior because,
in the beginning of the third term,
which is start to use George for approving his endless presidency,
uh,
saying that he's kind of a
kind of sent by God to be a president of Russia and fighter Curio who is the
head of Orthodox Church and very influential person in Russian society start to
approve this saying that true Christians should not go to the demonstrations.
Um,
and so on.
MMM.
Well,
so would you say to,
to do so,
so,
so pussy riot was formed,
uh,
you formed it with several other women.
Okay.
And not only women,
not only women,
but also men.
Yeah.
Yes.
Why not?
Very well.
And,
and as it came together,
you begin to,
uh,
organize what you call it,
actions.
Could you talk about a typical action you,
you write for example,
in the book about,
uh,
an action that global mes de,
which is a large stone platform,
uh,
near Red Square and outside the Kremlin walls.
Yeah.
What was,
what was a typical action like?
MMM.
Action isn't as a form of political art when you're doing action.
So before the Christ the savior,
we went to the Red Square,
which is the heart of,
I think called political field of Russia.
And
we came there with a song,
Putin pissed here's himself,
his pants.
Actually I think yes,
this correct translation.
Um,
and,
uh,
that's I think how the officials knew that we exist.
MMM.
How,
how are you want to describe?
So the action,
uh,
usually should be prepared.
So it's a bit different from the,
for example,
classico political rally.
So you're doing,
you should,
you should be prepared because you,
you will not have a second chance to it.
I mean,
you will have,
but in a different place.
And different place means different contexts and different statements.
So,
uh,
we went to the Red Square because we felt that we need to,
we need to protest there because that was a time,
uh,
of January of 2012 when
before the elections,
almost all the Russia was protesting.
I think it's a little bit similar of what's going on now in the United States
because somehow,
um,
Trump became a match for a people,
for the people,
uh,
to stand up and to,
to say the,
just spread the word.
So that brings us a bit forward in the story to the pump,
the pump prayer.
So this was the action that led to your arrest and detention and trial and
ultimately your imprisonment.
Um,
it took place in a large Russian Orthodox church in central Moscow Cathedral of
Christ the savior.
So I want to interject that I visited this place in 1989,
uh,
during the Soviet period are in today's guide.
Took us to this site.
Um,
it was a swimming pool,
a large outdoor swimming pool at the time.
Um,
it's still a cathedral had existed from the 19th century on that site,
uh,
but was torn down in 1931 in another religious purge.
And then since the fall of the Soviet Union,
uh,
Cathedral has been rebuilt on the site.
But you notice that you,
you note in your book that the Cathedral is not actually owned by the Russian
Orthodox Church.
No.
Nor is it always used in ways that,
um,
might associated with the church.
Could you say a bit more about how pussy riot selected this,
this site?
Um,
for the pump prayer action?
Yeah,
it's notes.
Oh,
well,
it's not just the church.
It's a huge complex,
um,
like upward chores,
let's say in lower charge.
And in the upper chores share arbitrage is a symbol of this collaboration
between Putin and butter because butter usually doing his speeches there and,
but in the Lord Church and both of them do not,
uh,
officially by law,
belonged to Russian Orthodox Church organization.
Um,
and there are a lot of kind of facilities there,
like laundry shop,
often serving years carwash,
uh,
and holes like rental halls,
rental rules for purchase.
Um,
which where you can not only have a party but rant
some Japanese techniques for music and invite some musical band there.
Um,
and generator of like heavy smoke.
He's just more,
uh,
these balloons and so on.
And
so,
um,
all this,
uh,
like list of what you can do there,
you can find in the official website.
And usually if you prepare something,
uh,
you,
start to read about this place since and so on.
So we went to the official website and,
uh,
we work with quite surprise.
Um,
and uh,
well,
um,
we just,
I mean we didn't ask any permission to,
to make a song there,
but yeah.
And the song was protests.
Um,
I think,
uh,
this is a,
let's say it's a big drama of our country because during the whole,
so it period Christianne she was banned in Russia,
in,
in Soviet Union and thousands of people were killed,
tortured,
sent to the endless prison terms just for being Christians,
just for praying,
for celebrating Christmas.
And now we have
it's situation when,
I mean Christianity is used by check is by the same organization which were
repressing them for almost a century.
And,
uh,
this is a very sad,
so,
and,
uh,
I think the difference,
of,
uh,
political art,
between,
for example,
political activism is not providing,
um,
only one right decision.
It's about asking questions which are not been asked before and which are
uncomfortable for government,
for example,
or for any authorities.
So,
and that's what we did.
We didn't say that we know,
uh,
how,
for example,
the church should exist in the right way.
We just said that we think that it's wrong.
How,
how it is
in the days after
the punk prayer or you went into hiding in Moscow for a number of days and then
you were arrested
yeah.
And almost the road more.
Yeah.
Yes,
because we changed floods.
Okay.
Good conspiracy floods every day,
changed phones,
uh,
Change Sim cards and so on.
Um,
so yeah,
it's one of my favorite part.
So your,
your first stop in your detention was in Moscow.
Uh,
as I understand it,
where you spent some months awaiting,
no,
it's not.
So,
okay.
One day rescue is they put you too [inaudible].
It's like the oldest prison,
all the jail in Moscow,
like from the side of video and so on from Warner here.
So they put you there and they are used,
spends five,
six days and after they put you to the jail where investigation gourds and
sentence.
So it's about eight months you're spending in the
women's jail,
which is the only one in Moscow.
And you described,
you described the trough guy as a place,
for example,
it was so cold and the building was so porous that um,
the,
the prisoners used,
um,
uh,
do from,
from their bread ration sanatorium at its most go jail,
Moscow jail to stuff into cracks in the wall too,
to try to insulate their selves.
So during this time,
uh,
when you were in detention awaiting trial,
what kind of access did you have to legal counsel to a lawyer and,
and also,
um,
to your family and uh,
others on the outside,
I had an access to a lawyer.
Uh,
but well worth it.
I think it's a bit different.
So your,
you have visits with lawyer and in the room,
in another building where from,
from where you,
your cell is.
And of course it's so old listened and so on.
Um,
so they can use any of your
talks anywhere,
not only in investigation protocols,
they can use it,
uh,
in governmental media for example,
because,
uh,
all the meters,
you know,
in Russia,
all the big media billows to friends of fortune.
So they provide a,
everything was they accept from the administration of the president.
Um,
so,
and about family to have a visit with your family,
uh,
you should have assigned paper from your investigator and I want just to get a,
he somehow lost about 10 papers,
um,
where I asked her this visit.
So,
uh,
no visits during the investigation.
Um,
after the trial I had one visitors,
but it's kind of hard to see your,
I mean,
to see your son between this gloss and so on.
What was,
except for that visit,
what was the total amount of time you were separated from your son?
Well,
I've been very in prison for two years,
but when they sent me after the sentence to the penal colony,
which is 3000 kilometers from Moscow,
uh,
I had to,
um,
once at three months visits,
uh,
with my family.
So they came,
uh,
does he know calling you to visit me?
Um,
so
you were charged with,
in English it translates to hooliganism motivated by religious hatred.
Yup.
Do you recall your reaction when you were told that was the charge against you?
I Dunno.
Yeah,
it was quite a surprise because,
um,
uh,
the law in Russia exist in the way that if you have just like hooliganism,
it's not,
um,
a criminal crime.
So you,
you can get up to 15 days in jail.
But if they find this motivation of hatred,
it's up to seven years.
Um,
well,
this kind of hatred can be different.
It can be political hatred,
social hatred,
and religious one,
which they somehow found,
uh,
in us in our song.
And,
um,
that was,
how,
this is a special part of the trial,
uh,
of approving that we really hated,
um,
the choice.
They said Christia issue,
which was fucking absurd.
The prosecutors analyze the lyrics of the songs in your performance,
especially experts,
especial experts analyzed our song.
And following that,
um,
the phrase holy shit means hatred to,
whole Christianity.
You
if you're saying you're holy shit,
it means that you hate
all Christian below rings and charge itself.
Yes.
I mean,
it's a fishery.
The trial
as often European,
holy shit.
It means like you more and more height the charge.
I understand
at the conclusion of the trial and there are people who really believe that,
that,
I mean
they believed that the testimony of these experts,
uh,
so the,
um,
at the conclusion of your trial,
you were sentenced to two years in prison and you were transported to a prison
camp and Pam [inaudible] very sneaky.
It's actually,
it's a small CG in fem region.
And Boris Yeltsin,
who was before him,
he was growing up at the city.
Oh yeah.
She was studied there and he was,
Whoa,
totally not.
The president
is,
you know,
what a small world,
um,
can you,
can you tell us a bit about the prison camp?
Um,
what was,
what was the environment like for you?
In Russia?
We have service system of,
uh,
of Soviets,
prison system or the [inaudible] system.
So we don't have prisons.
We have a
penal colonies,
let's say,
or labor camps.
So it's come a,
it's like a strange village.
Um,
was barracks,
uh,
buildings,
for example,
two floors building in one floor exist one unit in one unit.
It's 100 people.
So all of them are living together,
sleeping together in one in one bedroom and having,
for example,
three toilets or everybody's here and it's no hot water,
no medicine,
which is the main problem
and eats necessarily the work.
So all the prisoners work in the fabric,
which is another part of the zone or the,
you know,
calling you.
And this is the most cynical thing that's a,
the workers is a sewing,
a police uniform and the uniform for Russian army.
Yeah.
It's uh,
I mean,
and it's
almost not paid for that.
So it's like two free dollars per month as a salary.
And usually people who have no support from the outside should somehow decide
what they will buy cigarettes or I don't know those past,
uh,
well when,
when I came there,
uh,
the transportation is another kind of story.
Um,
I was quite,
because,
well,
all this women start to to tell me,
you what is going on.
But
they didn't do anything against it.
And I asked,
why,
why you just say that you will not go to work?
And some of these people were working for administration as a,
let's say spice.
Um,
and if you're saying something like that,
it means that you kind of preparing of disorganization of a regimen.
And they put me to solitary confinement for two months and two months.
So five,
five,
my almost five months in total and start to make different kinds of pressure to
me.
So,
uh,
we,
together with my lawyer and my friends,
uh,
decided to go to the court against them.
And after two months we would,
and uh,
that was the first court against the prison guards in the spinel Columbians.
Everybody were quite
surprised when you're released from solitary confinement?
No,
no,
no.
I won a court against,
um,
against prison guards against there.
Um,
for example,
if they find,
uh,
it's okay.
Okay.
For example,
they want to punish you inside prison.
So how they can do it.
Um,
they are finding that you somehow violated the regime and the rules of prison,
the official law
after this,
uh,
finding they writing your paper and this paper means that,
your kind of disciplinary punished,
uh,
they can,
I mean,
it's a whole porch.
The door,
like official one.
It's like a small court against a small court inside the prison.
So they wrote a number of these papers against me.
Uh,
and I went to the court to appeal and when I won eight,
uh,
people from prison guards who fired because they broke a law.
It's their is um,
and um,
and they start to kind of,
yeah.
Improve conditions.
So they start to recover barracks,
put up salaries.
Uh,
yeah.
This,
this things
you were released from your sentence a bit early.
Um,
what do you think motivated the government to declare an amnesty that impacted
your case at the end of 2013?
Uh,
it was,
um,
and months before Olympic Games.
So as you know though,
why didn't the game,
so the media and
in Sochi and Sochi,
yes,
came to Russia and Sancho.
Um,
what'd you learn?
She is to decide to make a good faces for the west and released us and the
[inaudible] Kaur who was also political prisoner who spent 10 years in penal
calling you who used to be a Russian,
let's see,
oligarch in nine chairs.
Uh,
so they released three of us,
um,
and some other political prisoners from Arctic Sunrise case.
I don't know.
Do you do know is it's,
it was actually no for Russian ecologists and Green Peas.
They,
um,
it's another story.
Anyway,
so they've used the number of political prisoners saying that,
uh,
hi guys.
We don't have political prisoners in Russia.
We were okay.
Uh,
so,
but we,
we went to the Sochi after a month,
I think amongst once a week.
And that was another story because we made an action there and it was
totally another Russian that we remembered.
You were,
you were assaulted in Sochi at least once.
Yeah,
of course.
Alex,
because Alex with,
whoops,
nothing.
Listen,
may I open up to some questions from my colleagues?
Yeah.
Let me pass around a microphone.
Hi Masha.
Uh,
so what are your main learnings from your life and what is currently your main
learnings?
Is that,
yeah.
Yeah.
So what,
what is the main message you want to bring to this country?
I think every learning,
I don't have to book her just to show the one example of how it is possible to
make a choice and the act.
But I believe that he's three off any country.
It doesn't let the Russia United States Great Britain made by people,
not by political leaders,
but by all of us.
And each of us has a own story and all the stories is actually a history of the
country.
So
it's okay.
It's um,
I know it's,
it doesn't sound like a statement or a message,
but I think,
uh,
this is what I want to say.
Next question from auction.
Um,
I'm curious,
uh,
in the sort of spectrum of different kinds of political action from more to less
radical for our true marching.
Also different things people can do in under a regime that's oppressive,
which are the most effective to actually bring about change in your opinion?
Any honest thing?
Actually,
I mean we have one effective manager,
uh,
whose name was styling and that was quite effective,
but
I think brought us,
do not work like that.
It's um,
it's about what's in your heart.
And um,
for example,
I,
I never,
I wasn't that nervous Dodd you,
uh,
or any Arctic set poetry.
So I never thought that,
uh,
if we'll have him with me,
never.
But,
um,
things happening sometimes.
So it's so most important.
Do not,
do not lose yourself and do not,
uh,
afraid to speak out.
It doesn't matter where is going on.
Maybe it's a,
it's a situation in the class where all older students are silent and you just
stand up and say something.
Do you teach you that you are not injury?
This is,
don't use the same.
Then going to the cause she drove for me it's the same level.
Okay.
Uh,
two questions.
Um,
what brings you joy and what are your future artistic plans?
Okay.
Whoa.
I like her.
I liked the action.
I like when I am doing something at the,
it works and I like to swim.
It's different things.
Um,
as a future blends,
blends,
I'm usually like doing what I feel.
So you've been a citizen activist and a prisoner,
prisoner of conscience in what most neutral observers would certainly call an
authoritarian regime.
Um,
what advice would you offer to people in other countries around the world who
might be concerned about creeping authoritarianism in their own societies?
Advice.
I mean,
when we started,
we were inspired by,
uh,
movements for from us and Lord from ride goals,
from the Kikuyu Cubans.
So it's,
you guys who give us advice is,
so
I think
you have an amazing culture on if we're speaking about freedom,
is it,
I mean United States was great.
It is a country of freedom.
So what advice I can give you,
this is very strange question.
Sorry.
Thank you.
So would that will come to a close,
I'll tell y'all supposed to him as I was crazy,
but
[inaudible] it was
learning Russian in school.
I was,
yes,
it's popular.
No,
no.
But why did you decide to launch version?
Well,
it was the Cold War.
It seemed like a valuable skill.